a maritime mystery played with
unanswered questions how did a 12 year
old girl and a 17 year old boy lose
their lives in these Waters
footage shared with Sky News from
Wednesday's incident shows a boat docked
at the pier as lifeguards treated the
injured on the beach it's believed to be
this boat now moored in pool Harbor and
now being guarded by police officers
have been examining it for a second
[Music]
day's coffee's hot chocolates feels more
in spirits and the selection of snacks
this video was taken by a passenger on
board
the charity director of the Royal
life-saving Society is familiar with
this beach dangers of the water he
reminds us are ever present although it
is shallow if even if you're standing in
a couple of foot worth of water even its
own up to your knees you will feel the
water moving you around so
it doesn't very likely chance that
underneath that Pier if there's a
channel that's pushing you back out to
see it's going to push you against one
of the Pier One of the groins and that's
why the lifeguards are so obverse to
keep people away from those spaces
during the half term break their job has
been even more challenging it's been
another hot day with the beach filled
with Sun Seekers and holiday makers the
events of Wednesday seem far away but
they are a reminder that when the sea is
involved things can change very quickly
thoughts turn to the families of the two
children at the center of this tragedy
their loss compounded by a lack of
answers
ashnaharanak Sky News in Bournemouth